FEMALE SPEAKER: Chef
Hugh is a father.
He's a chef.
He's an educating advocate.
He is the owner of two amazing
restaurants in the South,
in Atlanta-- the 5 &
10 and the National.
What was most striking
about, chef, your bio,
you're self-trained--
no culinary school.
So you can be this, too,
and get on "Top Chef."
What is so interesting and
wonderful about Chef Hugh
and why we wanted to work
with him is just this passion
you have about
teaching life skills
to all people and communities.
So without more, I just
want to introduce Chef Hugh.
Welcome.
HUGH ACHESON: Well, thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And we're
excited to have you.
And welcome to all the Googlers.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGH ACHESON: So
I'm Hugh Acheson.
I'm 522 months old.
And I have two kids.
And a lot of what we're
going to talk about
is a direct reaction to what
I see my kids going through
and what I want them
to attain in the world.
So, yeah, the story with
Beatrice is Beatrice was 11
and came home from school.
And let me first say this.
Our school district is great.
A lot of school
districts are great.
They're trying really hard.
But sometimes we need to
inject newness into curriculums
to make them that much better.
So she came home from her first
day of family and consumer
sciences, which is the
gender nonspecific term
for home economics because home
economics became something that
was teaching very much like
"how to raise your baby" type
of skills, which we'll all learn
on our own someday in life.
And maybe we need a
little bit of that,
but what I wanted it to
teach was life skills.
Yet it taught Beatrice how
to make red velvet cupcakes
from a box and how to pull
croissants out of a Pillsbury
tube and wrap them
in cheap bacon
and bake them in the oven--
and to take prenatal vitamins
at 11, which I don't really
ethically-- ethically I
don't care about.
Usually the vitamins
are like named something
like One-A-Day, which implies
the direction in the title.
So I didn't think that
was really necessary.
And I started to think
about life skills.
So I went to the school
superintendent for our region
and started talking to him.
And he said, yeah, I was about
to cancel that whole class
because it sucks.
And it got me thinking,
well, if it sucks
and we yank it
out of the system,
then we're still raising the
status quo, which is kids
who have no idea how to cook.
So I developed a curriculum.
And I went to him and said,
I think we can do this.
And he said, well,
why don't you do it?
And I said because
I have five jobs.
And I work 90 hours
a week already,
and I try and raise my family.
And so then I said,
OK, I'll do it.
So we're going live in four
middle schools in grade six
next year.
Following year, we'll
have grade seven.
have grade eight.
The core curriculum
is nine things.
It is a look at cooking overall,
which is really about five
or six of the things.
But it's life skills.
It's retainable things.
It's how to poach an egg,
which we're about to do.
It's how to make a vinaigrette,
It's how to build a
dinner effectively
for like $8 for four people.
It's things that hopefully
stick with people by the time
they get to 18, 19, 20-- the
hardest time in your life
when you have no money and
you're trying to figure things
out and it's just
hard to figure out
how to put dinner on the table.
This is things you can hearken
back to and say at least I
know how to poach an egg.
Well, right now
we just don't have
that sort of life skills
being obtained by children.
So this is that
way of doing that.
But it's also got a
lot of home finance.
It's got a lot of life hacks.
It's got a lot of DIY.
It's got a lot of basic
sewing because I was cool when
I was 12 because I could sew.
And I was a dude.
It was weird, but it
was really helpful.
And I still hem my own
pants-- not this pair.
So these are all life skills.
And I'll go over them
specifically in a little bit.
But what I think the most
telling thing about when
I explain this to people--
to doctors and lawyers
and hedge fund managers in New
York and coders and people who
work at big companies like you
all do-- is that they all say,
do you have a program
that I could take?
Because I'm not in
grade 6, because I need
to learn all that stuff, too.
Because you guys are super
smart, amazing, amazingly
productive people,
but a lot of you
have no idea how
to effectively put
dinner on the table that's
from scratch for your kids
or even just for yourself.
So these are life skills.
And I think that we
raise a better tomorrow
when we get all kids
knowing these basic things.
So if we have every kid knowing
how to poach an egg in America,
this is great.
So that's the end
result of this,
is hopefully that type of thing.
What we're trying to do in
building the curriculum is
we're having a big
charrette next month
with a lot of food policy people
and lawyers and architects
and designers and painters
and artists and coders
and all these different
people coming together saying,
what do we all need to learn?
What, as citizens,
do we all need
to know universally
when it applies to food,
and reading a lease, and
opening up your first bank
account, and all these
things that would contribute
to our wherewithal as humans.
What are those things?
So that's what we're
whittling down to.
And that comes in a month.
But we've already
got the basic idea.
So what I want to
do here is really
to hearken back to
this idea of food.
Now what happened with
food in the last 50 years
is that we all fell hook,
line, and sinker for fast food,
frozen food, prepackaged food.
Everything became so easy.
But as we stripped
away our skill sets,
and as we forgot how to
cook, and we say things like,
I used to make jam
with my grandmother,
we don't say things like I
used to make jam with my mother
because mom fed us Smucker's.
And we lost a skill
set when she did that.
And we didn't pass along from
generation to generation core
ideas of what we value
and what we believe in.
So this is trying
to get back to that
and trying to get to
that basic necessity.
It's kind of homesteading skills
for the urban environment.
So let's go over
what we're going
to cook today because it's
very, very beautifully basic.
When we talk about whole food
and the ease of whole food
and defeating this
era of convenience,
if this is inconvenient,
I don't know what's
really inconvenient about it.
Because this, we're
going to make a salad.
So first we're going
to cook some farro.
Cooked farro looks like this.
Farro's a whole grain.
It's an emmer wheat.
And it is an integral grain.
Sometimes it's washed and
stripped of the outer coating.
You want to find stuff that's
complete and still whole.
So that's going to go
into this pot over here.
And again, we're
going to show you
how to cook grains, which is not
rocket science because that's
two cups of water.
And that's a cup of farro.
And we're going to
put that in there
and season with a little salt.
What's salt?
Salt is a seasoning.
It brings out
flavor in our palate
and brings out flavor in food.
So we're going to
add that to that.
And we're going to
bring it to a boil.
And then we're
going to simmer it.
And it's going to be done.
So you can just look
away from things.
That's really easy.
Believe in leftovers.
If you're cooking for a family,
and you make roasted chicken
the night before with
farro, make extra farro
because the next day
you can take a salad,
and pack a salad
for the kids that's
pretty much this with
salad dressing on the side.
It makes things easier.
So if you work 13 hours
a day, which you all do,
I want to make sure that you
understand that the time it
takes to make a meal like
this is equivalent to going
to a Chick-fil-A drive-through.
It's a confused
chicken sandwich.
I admit it's good.
But it's politically--
it's a little shaky.
But what I want to do is
that 15 minutes that you
spend in line waiting
there, you can cook dinner
around your family
as they do homework
or as they sit and play.
And you would be amazed
at how kids learn.
I think we all have this
idea and inclination
that we know how kids learn.
Kids learn by experience,
by watching you,
by watching you be comfortable
in your environment
of a kitchen.
Your kitchen is the most
important room in your house.
Use it.
Don't be like a New Yorker and
store clothes in your oven.
That's weird.
So we're going to do that.
As the farro is cooking--
it's come to a boil.
I'm going to reduce
that down to a simmer.
So that's going to
be at around three.
This thing goes to 10.
It may be the spinal tap
version that goes to 11,
but I don't think so.
So I'm just going to stir that.
And we're going to
cap it and let it sit.
And that's going to take
about 20 minutes to cook.
So we're going to
make a vinaigrette.
It's funny the whole
aisle in the supermarket
is devoted to dressings
and salad dressings
when things like mayonnaise
are really easy to effectively
make at home from scratch.
They're oftentimes totally
preservative-free when
we make them that way, too,
and much healthier for you.
The way I think I want
to eat in this world
is knowing what I'm
putting into my body
and training myself
to understand
that if something's
pre-prepared,
I don't know exactly
what's going into it.
And a lot of times, it's
packed with sugars and things
like that that we
don't necessarily need.
There's a lot of food out
there that we are really
led to believe is good
for us, and it's not.
This is one fascinating thing.
Frosted Flakes and Raisin
Bran, which has more sugar?
Raisin Bran.
Isn't that insane?
I feel like we've been lied to.
But OK, that's fine.
We're moving on.
So what's a vinaigrette?
Vinaigrette's a ratio.
A lot of you do crazy math
or accounting or coding.
You want to attribute
things to numbers.
Well, it's a ratio.
It's three to one richness
in oil and one as in acids.
I want to make this a
little more bracingly acidic
because in the end, it's going
to be a salad with vegetables
and lettuce and farro, but also
this puppy, which is an egg.
And an egg on your palate
is much like eating fat.
So I want to balance with
hyper-acidic vinaigrette
to balance the fact that this
is more oil essentially going
into my ratio of a vinaigrette.
Makes sense?
So I'm going to amp it
up just a little bit.
So this is extra
virgin olive oil.
You don't have to buy the
most expensive olive oil,
but I don't think
at the pearly gates
or wherever you're
going after this,
you're going to feel that
bad about buying better olive
oil in this world.
So treat yourself.
So this is going to be
about three tablespoons.
And then we're going to put
a whole clove of garlic in.
And that's just going
to flavor it through.
But I'm going to cut in half
just to expose the flavor.
If you buy pre-minced
garlic, you've lost in life.
So you just need to learn
how to mince garlic.
It's not a big deal.
Do you know how
to juice a lemon?
Don't buy the plastic one.
I don't know what's in there.
But it's not cool.
Then we're going to put a
little bit of mustard in here.
Now these are all-- I'm
a big believer in food
should not be precious.
These are all
things you probably
have around the house anyhow.
So this is not confusing.
A little bit of salt.
A little bit of pepper.
And then some vinegar.
Now you could use any type
of vinegar that you want.
I'm using a cider
vinegar in this case.
But you could use
a red wine vinegar.
You can make your own vinegar
really easily as well.
And then this goes in.
And I'll tell you a little
Beatrice story in a second
as I do this.
Now this is that.
We're going to make an
emulsification by this.
So it's a workout as well.
This is not confusing.
This is food.
I'm trying to make sure you're
stripping away this idea
that food needs to be made
by somebody in a chef coat
with a fancy apron on.
I'm wearing a bespoke
apron right now.
But it's not a fancy apron.
So the vinaigrette's done.
If you wanted to make
extra vinaigrette,
you can make a ton of it
and store it in your fridge.
It's going to stay good in the
fridge for three to four weeks
easily.
The only thing that's going
to go bad in this vinaigrette,
really, is oil tends to
go rancid after a while.
But it was probably
rancid because you
bought it a year ago
anyhow in your cupboard.
But the garlic in
there will go off, too.
But that, really, is going
to take two to three weeks
to happen.
So you can make this
with fresh shallot.
You can finally dice onion.
Basically, the
ratio is the ratio.
And if you want to flavor
it with chopped-up kimchi,
that's great.
You want to flavor
it with hot sauce,
you want to use the lime
instead of some of the vinegar,
you just need to understand that
it's all based on that ratio.
And the flavor profile of
what you're looking for
is anything you want to make it.
On top of the ratio, you
can add different flavors.
So it could be soy.
And it could be ground sesame.
It could be whatever it is--
tahini or whatever it is.
So that's there.
We're going to begin to process
through some vegetables.
And then we're going
to look at our farro.
I've already got cooked farro.
So this is not really important.
It's kind of the TV switcheroo.
So in the recipes,
I broke them down.
And literally, they are the
simplest vegetables and things
to-- and simplest
recipes to make.
So if I go home
and I'm starving,
and my kids are by my side, I
would make Beatrice make this.
Because let's go
back to when Beatrice
was five years old and
going off to kindergarten--
and this pulls at my
heartstrings as a dad,
but also as a cook and
a chef and a proponent
of homemade food.
So I could hear this
clamoring first day
of kindergarten in the kitchen.
And Beatrice, I
can see looking out
my bedroom into the kitchen.
And Beatrice is there
standing on a stool
with a knife in her hand cutting
vegetables to make a salad.
And she was doing pretty
much what we're doing here.
And she was putting it into a
bowl that's got a sealable lid.
And she was shaking then a
vinaigrette off to the side
and pouring a little bit
of that and sealing it.
And that was her lunch
she was taking to school.
Nobody instructed
her to do that.
Nobody had taught
She had learned that
by watching me work
in the kitchen over the years.
Really perceptive kid,
and she's a sponge.
But that's what kids are.
They're sponges.
But Beatrice, just
as an example,
will have a much better life
because of the skill sets,
because of these
core ideas of food,
that she understands that this
is not precious, this is easy.
And that's what we need to get
across to this next generation
because there are so
many temptations in how
we feed ourselves every day.
There's so much ease out
there and what we think
is convenience.
But that convenience
catches up to us.
And that convenience has
caught up to our society
in the form of type 2
diabetes and obesity
and just loss of skill sets.
So Beatrice did that.
So I would go home now.
And I'll get Bea to make that.
I'll get Clem to make--
Clementine;s my other daughter
who's 11-- to make farro.
And she'll do it.
And we'll talk about what
happened during the day.
So cooking from scratch
is all about that.
But it's also what I just said.
We will talk about what
went on during the day.
I mentioned this earlier
because it's really important.
We do not have family
moments that we
remember over Pizza Pockets.
We have family moments
that we remember
that mean a lot to
us in our community
and in our household over
food we make from scratch.
Nobody wants to remember
a meal of a Pizza Pocket
because that's embarrassing.
OK, carrying on.
So I'm going to start
assembling my salad.
So this is just a really
simple like Little Gem or Bibb
lettuce.
Let's be abundantly clear about
what I believe about in food.
I am not a zealot.
If you bought this at the
grocery store, that's fine.
If you bought it on a
direct-to-your-door delivery
site on the internet,
that's fine.
If you stole it from
the cafeteria at Google,
that's fine, too.
What I want you to
do is just cook.
The best possible scenario
is you go out and find
the person who grew this stuff.
And on a Saturday, you go to the
farmer's market with your kids.
And your kids realize the
food doesn't just appear.
The food is tended to
by somebody with hands
and cultivates that out of love
and trials and tribulations
and the difficulties of farming
in North America these days,
and actually works at it.
And that work ethic, if I can
get Beatrice and Clementine
to understand that the
food does not just appear,
it makes food more precious
and more appreciated.
And I think that even kids have
a lot of empathy on situations
and are more prone to eat a
carrot that they know the where
it came from and
that somebody grew it
and somebody took pride in it.
Because we've lost pride
in food, and that's
what we need to inject
back into the scenario.
So I'm going to start
chopping up some vegetables.
This could be any vegetable.
If it was beautiful turnips,
Hakurei turnips and cucumber,
or it could be the
radishes or carrots,
but it could be
chopped up cabbage.
Basically, I'm just
saying it's whatever
you have in your fridge.
It's all food.
And I want you to use all
of it because the problem
with modern America is
we basically buy twice
as much food as we need.
And we waste half of it.
So that's up to
you to change that.
But it's little steps to
a better, bigger step.
So you have to start changing
the way we look at that.
So a lot of people
say, well, I'm
not going to get a
five-year-old a knife.
I'd give a
I'm actually more scared of
giving middle schoolers knives.
And let's talk about
middle schoolers
and how hard they
are to deal with.
They are complete sponges and
want to learn life skills.
They're also going
through a lot.
And in the American
child these days,
there's a lot of diversity in
what they're going through.
We taught knife skills
to a group class.
One kid cut
themselves on purpose,
which is a difficult
reality to set into.
So it's hard to justify giving
a bunch of knives to kids
and telling them go at it.
But most five-year-olds
actually probably cut better
than you do because you need to
learn the basic skills of it.
So when we talk
about knife skills,
you want to find
something that's sharp.
And that's good because
the wound's cleaner.
But if you see how I'm cutting,
I'm processing through.
And my actual--
this finger right
here is actually
touching the blade.
And my thumb is well behind.
And I'm doing a
little claw thing.
And slowly but
surely, I think what
you want to do with kids is just
show them what to do, and then
implore them to do
it better and safely,
and realize what they're
working with with knives.
But eventually they're
going to work with knives.
And you shouldn't be
scared about that.
So we're going to
do radishes as well.
And I love radishes.
And people are like, how do
I get kids to eat radishes?
Well, you give them
radishes, for starters.
A lot of people are like,
my kid won't eat that.
It's like if you've
never tried--
you know what we
don't do at my house?
We don't talk about what's
on the plate that much.
The plate is the plate.
There's no demarcated point that
you have to eat the vegetables.
It's just food.
It's all food.
It's a balanced food.
If you want to get your kids
to try and try more things,
eat family style.
So the four of you,
or six of you--
I don't know how big your
family is-- one of you, whatever
it is, lay out the food.
And if you've got a hungry
kid, they tend to go after it.
If you've got a kid you fed a
saccharin sweet 5:30 snack to,
your chances of success
at the 6:30 dinner
are very, very diminished.
Does that makes sense?
Basically, they're not hungry.
And basically, when they're
not really that hungry,
they're going to become
pickier about the food they're
going to eat.
I'm not saying
starve your child.
I'm saying you want to
push them to the fact
that there is a dinnertime,
that we have demarcated meals
throughout the day.
I live my life
snacking in kitchens.
It's not a great existence.
It makes me slim, but I
never really eat full meals.
It's a weird thing.
But OK.
So I think the 5:30
snack is not good.
You also want to
pick snack foods.
Snack time should be
like 3:30, not at 5:30.
So this is easy.
We've got our basic
salad made up.
If you wanted to add something
and make this a full my plate
experience of a
meal, what I would
add would be feta cheese
or chopped-up chatter
or whatever it is.
And that's going to add
just a little more protein.
If you want to add
tofu, you could.
If you wanted to add
steak from last night,
or that roasted chicken
pieces from last night,
you can do that, too.
It depends on what you want.
To me, this is a great meal
for a lunch just as is.
A dinner, I'd probably
add some protein.
Really, we're looking
at three components.
And they're all in the
recipes you've got.
So we've got the farro on.
We've got the vinaigrette done.
And then we're going to
make the poached eggs.
And then we're just going to
assemble everything and get it
together.
Let's go back to just
cost analysis just briefly
because I think this pulls away
from the preciousness of food,
too.
Look, if you want to buy
$12 a dozen eggs that
were from Martha, the egg-laying
chicken who is very pampered,
that's great.
You can buy those.
America still is buying
$1.50 and $1.75 a dozen eggs.
So if we equate price to
that, they're probably not
the best eggs in the world.
But there are eggs.
And again, little
steps win this war.
I'm not arguing about local and
sustainable organic right now.
I'm arguing about
core cooking skills.
I don't care where
people get it.
I just want them to
cook from scratch.
That's the first step.
Better food sourcing,
that's the second step.
Your ideal, which is buying
organically and locally
and sustainably, that's
a distant third step.
But we're way far away
from bridging that gap
right now because
most of America
has forgotten how to cook.
So this is the first step.
So in that argument
is to say this egg
is worth about a quarter.
The farro, a pound
of it's about $4
and will feed about 16 people.
So maybe this is $1, all of it.
And then the vinaigrette,
you've got about probably $0.25
a portion.
Olive oil is more
expensive than you think.
So that's maybe another $1.
And your vegetables
are probably $3.
So you're looking at kind of a
$6 meal for four people here.
So this idea that the
automatic assumption in value
is that we jump
to the Happy Meal
as being the best
value available.
Well, the Happy Meal is $4.50.
So if you do that two times,
and the other value meal
is at $6 each, you're suddenly
at around $20, $21, $22.
It's not a value.
We've been lied to.
So we need to fight back.
And the way we fight back
is we learn how to cook.
We learn that this
is our modern value.
So back to poaching eggs.
What's poaching?
It's not boiling.
It's kind of the
Jacuzzi of cooking food.
It's taking something
that wants to be
in a nice warm
environment slowly,
slowly cooking and sort of
nuancing it and coagulating
protein to an end result
of a beautiful thing.
I like my egg yolk to
be relatively soft,
but just set up.
It's sort of almost like
custardy in the center.
So I break into it, and
there's a slight ooze.
I don't want a liquid.
So we're going to show
you how to do that.
The first thing that's
going to go into the water
is just a little bit of salt.
This water is at around 160,
165.
And so boiling is 212.
So it's nowhere near
boiling, but you'll
see just little
traces of bubbles
on the bottom beginning to form.
The other thing
I'm putting in here
is just a little bit of vinegar.
And this is just a
still white vinegar
and that's just going to
help the egg whites coagulate
just a little more
closely towards the yolk
and not flutter around.
So the first step is you've
got your water going.
Realize you're putting four--
who universally travels here?
Or internationally travels?
If you travel in the universe,
you can tell me that, too,
because that's cool.
And that, we should
probably keep that hush-hush
if you guys are
really doing that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HUGH ACHESON: We understand.
HUGH ACHESON: I remember going
to Spain about 10 years ago
and looking for eggs
at the grocery store.
And it took me forever
because contrary
to North American culture, they
don't refrigerate their eggs.
I'm not a food safety expert.
I'm a chef.
You don't really need to
refrigerate your eggs, either.
If you put this as straight
out of the fridge times four
into 165-degree water, and
these are at 38 degrees,
you're going to plunge the
temperature of that water
to way below a
poaching temperature.
It's kind of like putting
ice cubes in water.
You're going to
chill it down a lot.
Or frying chicken
and wondering why
it's like poaching in oil after
you put it in there because it
was almost frozen chicken.
Does that make sense?
So we want to bring these
up to room temperature.
And then we're
going to add it in.
So room temperature is
sort of 75, 70 to 75.
That's not going to affect it
as much as them being 38 to 40.
So those are that.
We're going to create--
you can go-- you
do this backwards in Australia.
But we're going to go like that.
And then that's just going to
help everything bind together.
You see the white go around.
And we're just going
to continue that.
And that white's just going
to grab on to that as we go.
And you see it
beginning to grab on.
As it's swirling, it wants
to grab back on to that.
And it's doing exactly
what it's supposed to do.
Just want to make sure it's
not sticking, which it's not.
Right now this is at six
out of 10, which is 60%.
Math class was very good to me.
So we're just going
to stir that again.
And again, we're going
to drop those in.
You can drop all four in,
which we're going to do.
I do put them in these little
ramekins ahead of time.
And that just-- ooh,
that's a big yolk.
The other ones were little.
Eggs.
Food, the modern miracle.
So we're stirring that around.
And we're just going
to get that in there.
And stirring it around
just a little bit.
I don't want to break my yolks.
Now we're going to let those go.
It's going to take about
three to four minutes.
But what I want you to do is
realize that you read a recipe,
and you read through it
and you think you got it,
and nothing really goes right.
Well, food is a nuanced thing.
We love restaurants.
Sometimes they're
really consistent.
But that's a really
difficult thing to do.
It's doing something--
I mean, there's
a lot of different
things going on
and a lot of different
people's responsibilities
in the kitchen.
So you just want to
watch it and begin
to understand the
nuance of food and when
things are naturally done.
So in getting this
together as a final,
I want to give a little bit of
toothsomeness-- how are you;
you're good-- to this pharaoh.
So it's cooked already.
It's plumped out.
It's tender, but
not really soft.
But I'm going to crisp
it up by just putting
a little bit of oil in the
pan, getting this heat up
to about seven, and
then we're going to just
put a little bit of it in.
And I just want to give it
a little different crunch
on the palate.
And this is, again,
kids like texture.
We like texture in food.
I think we like big
flavors more than ever.
We've internationalized
our food in North
America in the last
five years more
than it ever has in like 100.
So our familiarity with
kimchis and fermented foods
overall is beyond where
it was five years ago.
So feel free to add whatever
you want to this type of thing
to make it more fit your palate.
So that oil is just shimmering.
Oil obviously is thicker
at a colder temperature
so it thins out as
it's warming up.
And you just want to see as
it races down the pan just
how it's moving.
But again-- and then we don't
want it to be smoking, though.
Olive oil has got a
pretty low smoke point.
You could do this in
a grapeseed oil, which
is a neutral oil with a
much higher smoke point.
And that would be good, too.
And we're not trying to make
popcorn or popped farro, which
you can make.
It's actually really good.
And we're just going to get a
little bit of texture on this.
So that's all in there.
I'm going to check on my eggs.
How are you guys?
I often cook and
talk to myself a lot.
That's OK.
So that's just going to
sizzle out and do its thing.
And I'm going to
season a little bit.
Now seasoning is, again, it's
different in every household.
Just realize what
you want to attain.
I just want to make sure
the food's fully-- has
a lot of flavor going on in it.
So I'm going to
re-emulsify my vinaigrette.
In the fridge, if it
separates, that's fine.
Olive oil, when it's cold,
obviously, is pretty solid.
So you want to take
it out, temp it.
You can temp it in the
microwave if you need to.
Nobody uses those
things anymore.
And then we're going to toss
everything together and begin
to plate.
Would my kids eat this?
Yes, if they were hungry.
They still am-- I mean,
my kids are not perfect.
They still jones for
the Chick-fil-As,
as we've talked about.
But they would eat this.
And you could add prosciutto
to it or salumi or whatever
it may be.
It's just, to me, this
is the 10-minute meal
because the farro maybe is
already cooked from last night.
Basically, the
vinaigrette's already made.
Basically, you're
giving yourself
building blocks, which
is exactly what I'm
trying to give to the kids in
this Seed Life Skills thing.
So why does this apply to you?
Because the better you eat,
the more productive you are.
The better you eat,
the healthier you feel.
And the better you
eat, the more closely
you have a relationship
with your kids.
And the more you cook
food with your kids,
the more enabled
they are to get--
to have those life
skills that are really
going to pertain when they're
out on their own later in life.
Let's see.
Let's go over the
basics of the curriculum
because it's pretty interesting.
So it's got nine components.
One of them is life hacks.
It's leadership.
It's talking about
how we talk to people
and how we-- it's
basically the manners.
When we look at a
dated curriculum,
there's that manners protocol.
And somebody was
like, well, do you
want us to teach
them how to have
dinner at a fancy restaurant?
And I'm like, no, I don't care.
I want you to teach how
to talk to the bank teller
or how to walk into a
room and feel confident.
And those are the types of
things that I think they need.
This is all about
just empowering kids.
That's it.
So the second one is kitchen,
home, and health fundamentals.
Right now, home ec curriculum
spends about a week
talking about
different sort of risks
in cooking food and botulism
and all these things.
And my mandate on
that is they need
to learn that in
about 15 minutes
because there are
risks in cooking food.
And they're there.
If you're smart about it,
they're rarely, rarely,
rarely going to happen.
Botulism cases are
few and far between.
If you're going a
home canning bent
and have no idea
what you're doing,
you're probably on
a dangerous path.
So as long as you
know what you're doing
and are following pretty
simple food safety stuff,
yours should be good to go.
And then health fundamentals
is how to balance a diet.
What really is eating?
Right now, we've got
93% of American kids
do not eat enough vegetables.
That's across the board.
That is from wealthy households
and poor households--
and at 93%.
So it's teaching kids
that vegetables are not
that part of the
plate that you're
going to feed to the dog.
But it's that part of the
plate that you really revel in.
And the only way you get
the kids to eat vegetables
these days is you start
very, very early in life.
If a kid doesn't
like a beet at age 2,
they don't like sugar
because beets are 90% sugar.
I mean, that's what they are.
They're like nature's candy.
So we just need to think
along the lines of how do we--
but teaching a
15-year-old to eat a beet?
Have fun with that.
Let's look over our eggs.
Our farro's pretty much done.
I'm just going to spoon just a
little bit of warm liquid on.
They're just about there.
As you can see, the egg
white's taken shape.
The egg yolk is just
beginning to come to temp.
That's an [INAUDIBLE].
So we're getting there.
It just needs a
little bit more time.
These days, I love-- OK, let's
talk about vegetables overall,
too, in that we're from
a generation-- well,
I'm older than most of you.
We're from a generation that
hated vegetables because nobody
knew how to cook them.
Now we live in a society
where these people
know how to cook cabbage and
Brussels sprouts and carrots
in 25 different ways.
Well, our mother
knew how to cook them
in one, which was cook
the hell out of it.
That's not a really
great primer on how
to learn to love vegetables
and appreciate them.
But now we're in a better state.
So I can feed a kid
charred cabbage,
and they will eat a
whole plate of it.
I'll feed them
buttered sauerkraut,
and they will be like,
this is crazy good.
It's like rich and nuanced,
but it has the sourness to it
that's wonderful.
And so it's exploring
different parts of the palate.
And before, we're exploring
just overcookedness.
So this is the idea.
So that's the
skill sets we have.
So if you're not
getting vegetables
in front of your kids,
you're just losing out
because we've learned so much.
We've come so far.
Vegetables are so good.
And vegetables are the best deal
in the market in the grocery
store.
So then we go to
ingrained cooking
with grains and legumes.
In 1944, there was a
presidential mandate
to enrich rice.
We have stripped nutrition
by farming in such a bad way
that rice had no
nutritional value.
So that's why you
see enriched rice now
is because it was the
main diet of soldiers.
And the soldiers were
basically collapsing
on the field of battle
because they were eating crap.
So we need to get away from
this idea of enriching stuff,
of having milk filled with omega
3s and all this extra nutrients
and vitamins.
I like that idea for
keeping a kid upright,
but I want to empower that kid
to be upright on their own,
not have to think
about it, that they
get a balanced and
full died from eating
the proper things in life.
And that's the way they live
their healthy lifestyle.
So I don't think
that's that difficult,
but that's where
we're at in that.
So you know, it's fun to try
and convince a kid to eat well.
But when they do it and
they're on their own
and really doing
it, it's exciting.
So my eggs are done.
I'm just going to let
them hang out over here.
So anybody got any
questions so far?
The eggs are-- the yolk
is just custarded out
and exactly where I want.
Let's go over some of the
other ones just quickly.
So grains would be whole grains.
So it's wheat berries
and amaranth and farro--
things that are coming into
our popular vernacular of food
again.
So it's a really exciting time.
The next generation is
going to know a lot more.
So we need to introduce
them to them now.
So you guys just need to
learn how to cook them.
But again, it's dropping them
in water and covering a pot
and seasoning.
This is not rocket science.
This is just really, really,
really, really, really
simple straightforward food.
Then talking about agriculture
and modern food systems
in the form of making a salad.
Where's all the stuff from?
Why is it pertinent?
And why it matters.
Then cooking an egg
and roasting a chicken.
If you know how to
roast a chicken in life,
you're better than 90%
of chefs out there.
So go and learn how.
If you want the single best
roasted chicken recipe,
it's in the Zuni cookbook,
which was written
by an amazing woman
named Judy Rodgers, who
is a chef at Zuni in San
Francisco, who passed away
about five, six years ago.
And it is an amazing recipe
on how to take a great chicken
and make it ethereally good.
And if you don't feed
that chicken to a kid
and they don't
like it, they just
don't like food, and move on.
They move out at 18.
You'll be fine.
But the idea of cooking
well is not over our heads.
It's a really simple
recipe and really doable.
And then putting up is
preservation of food
and the importance of
and the idea of
preservation of food.
So we just need to think about
all of those things as well.
And then we're going into home
finance and how to read it.
So I moved out of my house
when I was 17 years old.
I signed my first lease
when I was 17 and 1/2.
I lived with a friend for a
couple months before that.
I had no idea what I
was signing, no idea.
Nobody told me.
Nobody told me that this
was a legal document.
was the rent stipulation
and it would go up
next year by this.
And I was signing
a two-year lease.
And it was a huge jump.
So nobody's teaching
these kids these things.
Nobody teaches them adequately
why you don't get a 24% APR
credit card.
And we have kids
going through life,
and then they make
crazy, crazy mistakes
that would have been so
avoidable if they'd been just
taught earlier in life
that maybe you shouldn't
lease your first
car as a Mercedes
if you make $23,000 a year.
Because companies are
very excited to lease one
to you because they're
not going to tell you
about the ramifications
you're having on your credit
rating and your life.
So that is a matter
of hedge fund
managers and financial advisors,
basically whittling down
with me and saying,
these are the core things
that we see all the time.
These are the issues.
And these are the
pratfalls and pitfalls.
And this is how you avoid it.
And then the rest of
it is just life hacks.
It's DIY.
It's how to tie knots so
things really stay down
so they don't fly off
the top of your car
when you got the Christmas
tree, and then it's
not there anymore, because
that's really embarrassing.
It's on the side of the 101.
That's not cool.
So learning how to tie knots.
Again, it's life skills.
I grew up sailing.
I knew how to tie knots.
This is kind of like Boys
Scout/Girl Scout empowerment
merit badges for everyone.
So it's also how to sew on a
button and hem a pair of pants
because, as I said before, those
are really important skills.
So it's all these
things-- how to fix things
before you replace it.
So it's not all-- not all
of it has to do with food.
But it's all applicable.
I'm going to salt
this a little bit.
I'm going to get
my farro into this.
It's still a little bit warm,
but it doesn't have to be.
Yours isn't.
And we're going to-- you guys
have Sweet Green out here yet?
So you can feed for the whole
family for the price of one
trip to Sweet Green in New
York, which is like the future
of fast food, it's basically
a salad joint, in New York---
where it started in Philly--
fastest-growing thing in food.
Shush, shush, shush.
Hold on.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HUGH ACHESON: It talks to me.
This is an induction
burner, which
is-- they're great and
annoying at the same time.
So the vinaigrette's
going to go on.
You can use as much
vinaigrette or as little.
Remember, it's a pretty
bracingly acidic vinaigrette.
I'm going to get my garlic back.
And then we're just going to
toss this lightly to season.
Again, I'm going to put just
a little bit of salt in.
Everything in moderation.
If you wanted to do this and
then go out for ice cream,
live large.
Have fun.
And then we're
going to plate it.
Now this is the other
thing about America
right now is that we eat
too much of a lot of things
we shouldn't eat.
So in this case, if I
was to have a steak,
I would have three
ounces of meat.
So a pound of steak
feeds my family of four
very well even after
butchery and stuff like that.
It's just we eat too
much of that stuff.
And a lot of that's tied to
sustainability and how we farm,
and what's really possible
for the long term.
But it's a conversation we need
to have with our kids, too.
You guys are making a ton of
strides here in sustainability.
Google food is really, really
amazingly forward-thinking
on these type of things.
But it's something we need
to talk to Middle America
about as well.
But Middle America is holed up
in Oregon right now with guns.
So that's pretty much it.
And you could do two eggs
if you want a heaping
amount of protein on it.
You don't need that.
And so why do we do this?
Why am I doing this?
I'm doing this because
kids, they need our help.
And it's not just our kids.
It's all kids.
I send my kids to
public school not just
for-- my kids will be fine.
They're fine.
I send them there because
the other kids' parents
work three jobs and
make $20,000 a year.
And their kids are floundering
because they can't be involved
in the PTO or whatever.
So we're engaged.
And we're lucky in this
society to have the ability
to be engaged.
So I'm engaged for all
kids to make this better.
And we make it better by
giving them basic ideas.
So to me, this is the basic
idea that every kid-- this
is a right that they
should learn this.
It is not a skill set to
go to McDonald's and get
a Happy Meal.
But this is skills
that everybody can do.
Like, if you guys can't do all
of this from start to finish,
I'd be amazed.
I'd be utterly, utterly amazed.
But if you can teach
your kids to do this,
you don't worry
about them then when
they're 20 because at least
they know how to do this.
Does that makes sense?
So it's skill sets for everyone.
And that's kind
of the whole idea.
The eventual is we've got a box.
And the box is a curriculum.
And we can get that to
curriculum to Portland, Oregon,
to Portland, Maine, to Wichita--
anywhere, any private school,
charter school, or public school
that wants it free of charge.
And it is a curriculum
box that you open up.
And it's got teacher
training on the top
for two days,
interactive videos,
a lot of retainable
sort of videos that
go along with the course load.
All the nine modules
are packed together
and fits the timeline
of your classroom.
The reason I did this particular
style of fitting this in is
we've got the school gardens.
We've got school
nutrition and empowerment
and redoing of school lunch.
And nobody is tackling
the most important thing
in the middle, which is
we're not teaching kids
how to boil water.
So we need to do this.
Or we're wasting time
and we're falling
into the trappings of modern
society more and deeper
every day.
The other reason I
did it is because I'm
the son of an economist.
And this is imminently doable
because these classrooms
exist, the curriculum
is still being taught,
though a lot of schools
are jettisoning it.
So before they jettison
it, I need to swoop in
and say, you can do this.
You've got great teachers.
I want to give them something
that makes their life easier.
that is really, really
easily teachable and that
everybody can learn from.
The other thing I want to do
is develop an adult curriculum
because as I said, the feedback
from adults that I talk to
is, how can I take this course?
So we all need this.
But we need like a Khan
Academy of life skills.
We need that sort of
modules on YouTube
that teach us how to do
the most basic things.
They exist, but
occasionally you find
that really weird
guy in a Speedo
teaching you how
to roast a chicken.
And that's not cool.
So YouTube, it's
a weird terrain.
So this is more a
place where you can go.
And this is life skills.
So that's it.
But anybody got any questions?
AUDIENCE: Really quick
question about farro.
So the more and more I
shop, I see quick grains,
so like five-minute farrow.
HUGH ACHESON: Yep.
AUDIENCE: My question is
it looks the exact same--
HUGH ACHESON: Eh.
AUDIENCE: --but what
do they do to it?
And are you losing any
nutritional benefit by--
HUGH ACHESON: You are.
AUDIENCE: --using a quick grain.
HUGH ACHESON: Yeah,
it's the same thing.
It's like, I talk a lot about
the advent of Minute Rice.
How hard do things have to
be when we minutize them?
So I mean, farrow cooks
in 15, 20 minutes.
So if you buy-- basically,
that's pre-cooking it,
drying it, and then-- so it's
just you're re-hydrating it
in five minutes.
So what I want to
do is teach people
the beauty of cooking
something from raw, the ease
of cooking something from raw.
And I want to get
back to a society that
doesn't feel like spending 10
more minutes in the kitchen
at the stove is an inconvenient
move or a loss of time.
It's also going to strip a lot
of nutrients in that process.
And it's also just going through
so many more hands and machines
that I just think I can
simplify the process.
So convenience through
inconvenience from convenience.
I don't know if that
makes any sense at all.
But yeah, but yeah.
Anybody else?
FEMALE SPEAKER: We've
got one right here.
HUGH ACHESON: Yes
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for joining us today.
HUGH ACHESON: Thanks
for having me.
AUDIENCE: I have a really quick
story and then a question.
I have a nine-year-old
and a three-year-old.
And a couple of weeks
ago, my nine-year-old
was just having a
really, just, like,
one of those
complainy boring, I'm
bored nights and just
agitated and off.
And I asked him if he
wanted to cook with me.
He did.
He chopped all kinds
of things-- mushrooms,
carrots, all kinds of things.
And it was amazing how his
mood just changed and happy
and when can we do this again.
So just thank you
for reminding us
that these are things we
should all do together and also
have those daily conversations
while we're doing it.
My question is, if I recall
correctly from the last time
you were here, you're not fond
of the ingredient delivery
services.
Is that right?
I was wondering if
you could just--
HUGH ACHESON: We'll
talk about it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so I don't know.
I've been doing it a bit.
And it's actually gotten me
cooking more, which I like.
HUGH ACHESON: That's good.
And not good.
AUDIENCE: But I was wondering
if, for you, it was more of a--
because from a cost
perspective, you're
just paying way too much.
Or if it's from a pride in
your cooking perspective,
that we haven't chosen
the ingredients ourselves.
HUGH ACHESON: You're
on the right path.
Look, anything, any
move you can make
to cook more from
scratch at home--
and basically these
companies like Blue Apron are
very smart companies in
kidding you out with mise en
place so you can cook at home.
It's just you're really trapped
into their way of thinking.
And it becomes very expensive.
What I want to do is make
sure that you understand that
cooking should be your
adventure, not somebody else's.
I think you should pick
up a recipe from any book
or from a magazine
and just embark on it.
But you need to
be able to atomize
the skill sets that you're
learning because cooking to me
is like a LEGO set.
Each little piece is a
skill set in the kitchen.
Well, I just have a
bigger LEGO set than you.
So I can build big things.
But we all need those LEGO sets.
And I want you
all to build them.
But Blue Apron's good.
And the only other problem
I have with Blue Apron is
I'm a really,
really big advocate
of making sure everybody in this
world has the ability to cook.
And when we talk
about those services,
they're really expensive.
So my job is to make sure
that everybody understands--
from the mother on food
stamps in Detroit--
this meal is a value.
This meal is a
value for everybody.
And it is so easy.
So there's a complexity
that some of those services
want to implore you to
cook something complex.
And I like that.
First step is the core
idea of food again,
is the core idea of I want
you to make a salad dressing.
It's so easy.
And so that's the idea.
I want you to make
the perfect omelette
If you want the best way,
Ludovic Lefebvre of Petit
Trois.
And he's on TV.
He's on "The Taste."
He's got this amazing
omelette recipe.
And it's so easy.
But now Beatrice makes
that omelette all the time
in this little
French omelette pan.
I mean, it's the perfect
tri-fold, no color on it,
just custarded eggs
with chives on top.
And it's stunning,
finished with butter
and stuffed with boursin cheese.
It's not expensive or precious
food, but it's technically on.
And that's what I want.
I want people to get so excited
about that type of attribute
of food that if I can cook an
egg perfectly, I'm winning.
You know?
And that, that to me is a
skill set anybody can learn.
And it's to me it's so exciting.
And you talked about
changing your child's mood
when they actually engaged
in something in the kitchen.
Well, it was because they're
doing something with you.
And you were doing it together.
And that, you know, that
to me is like something
that you can never replace.
So somebody says, well,
cooking's inconvenient?
I'll take that
inconvenience every day
of my life, that connection
I have with my kids
and watching them
bloom and watching them
be there and learn something.
And I had a good time.
And they got well fed.
And they learned something.
And it's just better.
It's so-- I don't know--
lofty as a dorky goal,
but so simple as well.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for all
the content and everything.
I think it was awesome.
My question is related
to what you brought up
about allowing kids to cut.
I'm actually quite happy
that over the past few months
I've been involving
the kids in the kitchen
and stuff like that.
The one thing-- I have two
kids, an eight-year-old
and a five-year-old.
I just had the courage to give
my eight-year-old a knife.
And he's now chopping
a little bit.
But I haven't been able to
do it with my five-year-old.
How could you and what
would you suggest?
And how can I encourage him to
use a knife but do it right?
I haven't taught
them right at all.
They will chop
their fingers soon.
But I'll try to
do the claw thing.
HUGH ACHESON: There
are starter knives
that you can buy at kitchen
supply stores and Williams
Sonoma and places,
Sur La Table that
are kind of smaller,
slightly duller knives,
usually brightly colored.
The scariest [INAUDIBLE]
from the kitchen
is a big, very sharp knife.
But to me, the scariest
knife is a dull knife
that's going to cut me badly.
Or the really scary one
is a serrated knife.
So cutting things that
are difficult to cut
with a bread knife that's
sharp, bread knives
will mangle you up.
So don't do that.
But just a small,
manageable knife--
I think a paring
knife-- and just, look,
if it's a five-
or a six-year-old,
you have to be there
right there with them.
You can't turn around.
But it's training
about, I don't really
cut myself cutting anymore.
But I will cut myself
putting my knife in my bag
or moving around the
kitchen and swiping
my hand across the
cutting board and pfft.
So it's reminding a kid
that this is a tool.
And it's a dangerous tool.
But it's a really important
tool to learn how to use.
So we respect it.
And you lose the
respect for it, you're
not allowed anywhere near it.
You have utter respect for it.
Even at five, kids
will understand that.
And I think that's a really
important lesson to learn,
that you can burn
yourself at a stove
if you're not paying attention.
You can knock a pot
of water on your foot
if you're not paying attention.
That's why we pay
attention in cooking.
This is serious
in a lot of ways.
I want you to have a lot
of fun, but it's serious.
So Clementine gets admonished a
lot, my nine-year-old-- or now
11-year-old-- for not paying
attention in the kitchen.
But, you know,
slowly, but surely,
she understands that if
she wants to be there,
she's got to take
it pretty seriously.
So no texting.
My kids are at that age.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is [INAUDIBLE].
And I just want
to say thank you.
HUGH ACHESON: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I really think
what you're doing is spot on.
This is something
I've been looking for.
I have a five-year-old.
And the last two years-- I'll
just kind of give a story-- we
set up meals for the week.
And we allow her, my
daughter, to pick a meal.
And she'll pick random things.
Like last week, she
picked French toast.
And we had it for dinner.
And we go and find a recipe.
We force her to write
everything down.
And we go to the grocery
store and buy it.
And we make it.
So that's how we kind of get
her involved in the whole meal
at home.
And I think I was just saying
that story because that
could be something
part of your program
if that makes some sense.
HUGH ACHESON: Yeah, it is.
AUDIENCE: For families,
I mean, that's
something you could
coordinate relatively easy.
HUGH ACHESON: Yeah.
And I think that the idea
of finding a regularity,
that she's picking a recipe
that she wants to do every week.
But also, you guys realize
the best written cookbooks
and the best written
recipes are some the best
reading you'll ever read because
it's fully instructional.
And instructional
writing, as you all
know because a lot of you do
it with what you're doing,
is really, really difficult.
We get comments still from
the first cookbook I wrote on,
it was good, but you
didn't tell me not
to put the egg shells in there.
So, you know, I mean, people are
morons when it comes to food.
So a recipe has to be fully
enveloping of everyone.
AUDIENCE: It's true.
HUGH ACHESON: So
it's key for kids
to read those and
cadence through them.
And kids are a lot smarter.
You know, if Beatrice is reading
a recipe, you guys'll scan it.
You're reading all the time.
You're busy.
You'll scan it over
really quickly.
And it's not really sinking in.
Beatrice will sit down with
it and take notes first
and realize, like, sort
of plot out her timeline.
She's very methodical.
You can't skim over this.
We're teaching
kids how to learn.
So you have to teach them
how to engage with the recipe
and fully understand it
before they embark on it.
It's like all of us just
assume that we know how
to use the gizmos on our car.
And we just don't because our
cars are so gizmoded out now.
So it's that type of thing.
But kids have an amazing
amount of patience
when you find them
in the right time.
So I have no problem with a
kid reading that and helping
me prep it out and showing
the sequence of it.
And it's beautiful to watch them
sort of get excited about it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I mean,
it was pretty successful.
But my real question
was, I cook quite a bit.
And I notice I
use too much salt.
And I'm just trying
to understand
what alternates do I have
because eliminating it
just-- it's not good.
But I do want to see
a reduction of salt.
And I don't know if there's
good alternatives that give you
that flavor as a substitute?
That's my question.
HUGH ACHESON: Adding
salt's a hard one.
I mean, you want to
season appropriately
to bring stuff
out, but you don't
want things to taste salty.
Your doctor is always going
to say you're probably
ingesting too much salt.
Usually how you're ingesting
too much salt is you're putting
together a lot of processed
ingredients that you have
no understanding of how
much salt's in there.
When you're adding
the salt yourself
in a home-cooked
environment from scratch,
it's at your control.
So that's the best way of
cooking and controlling
salt amounts.
But you want to make
sure-- food that's
really under-salted is dull.
So you can add other things
that will amp up flavors.
So hot sauces and things like
that, or fermented foods.
But a lot of those contain
a lot of salt, too.
A slice of bacon is
pretty much enough salt
as you need the entire
day because the curing
process of making bacon.
But then again, if I can find
a nitrate-free one that's
a little less salt that's really
good and from a local purveyor,
and I know the ingredients
that went into it
and I know the veracity
of it, I'm more likely.
But also-- I don't know--
the last time I checked,
I just live once, at
least in my belief system.
And I want to enjoy the food.
I want to have fun.
So everything in moderation.
Look, have fun in life.
But having fun is
eating good food
and enjoying it, and enjoying
it with the loved ones
you have in that amazing room
that you don't use enough
called your kitchen.
So enjoy.
I wouldn't worry too much about
the salt. I'm not a doctor.
I don't even play one on TV.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Adelle.
And my daughter
is 21 months old.
So I've been
struggling with cooking
for her for the past year.
So your class is very inspiring.
And I just have
a quick question.
When should I start
giving her salad?
HUGH ACHESON: When should
you start giving her salad?
AUDIENCE: Because right
now, she wouldn't eat raw.
She probably would
taste a little bit
of carrot, but definitely
not a cucumber or radish.
So what's the approach?
HUGH ACHESON: What
does she love?
AUDIENCE: Rice.
And cheese.
Yes, she loves cheese.
HUGH ACHESON: I mean, I would
just start introducing stuff
slowly, but surely-- tiny,
little cubes of cucumber
and lightly cooked carrot, and
then moving towards raw stuff.
Raw vegetables really are
immensely better for you
overall.
They're just better
for your system.
Our bodies are really
trained to eat them well.
So I think just
slowly, but surely.
I think you'd be
surprised at what she'd
eat if she was in a hungry
frame of mind and a good mood,
and you gave her some rice
and some cheese and three
other vegetables and you
didn't even talk about it.
And don't even talk about it.
It's just stuff on a plate.
And let her go at it.
But I think as soon as we
start to question what's
on the plate, as soon as we
start to territorialize what's
on the plate as things
that have to be-- that are
healthy and good
for you, I think
we ostracize that
part of the plate
and ostracize it
mentally in their mind
that they're not
going to go there.
Or that there's going to
be a fight going there.
When I don't talk about it,
you see this little thing
happening.
You know?
And sometimes they're like,
oh, I kind of like that.
And so kids want to go
against us naturally.
They like that.
So don't let her do that.
She's only 21.
You can take her.
Don't be pushed around.
AUDIENCE: I couldn't
help notice this is--
you made it look so simple.
And yet it was so tasty,
amazingly delicious.
HUGH ACHESON: Simple.
Food.
AUDIENCE: I had a
question about dressings.
You mentioned the ratio
as an important component
to dressing.
But what other components
can go into a dressing
to make it appetizing for
someone to have salad?
I noticed that you didn't
add any sweet component
to the recipe.
That's something we find a lot
more in dressings these days.
HUGH ACHESON: It's weird.
I grew up-- I have
a strange palate.
My dad raised us.
So we ate canned
yellow wax beans
and burned rice and fish
sticks most of the time.
So everybody's like,
oh, you must have come
from a really fancy household.
And I'm like, no, my dad's a
tenured economics professor.
He did not feed us well.
But we ate.
And it was fine.
But one thing I never
liked was sugar in food
that I thought
shouldn't be sweet.
It just didn't
really work for me.
And that stuck with me.
But now there's a big trend
of sugar in savory food.
And oftentimes it's pulling from
other cultural-- other places
in the world.
So Vietnamese cooking has
a lot of cane sugar in it.
Thai food's got a lot
of cane sugar in it.
Southern United States food
has a lot of honey and sorghum
and sugar added to things.
But that's never been
good for my palate.
So I keep the vinaigrette
light in that way
because I don't
want that interplay.
But you could add a little bit
of-- a tiny bit of molasses
with soy.
Soy and molasses go
really well together.
You could add a
little bit of honey
or just a really good
honey or something
like that to broaden it out.
But really the base ratio of
three to one of oil to vinegar,
oil to acids, that's
just a foundation.
You can build up from there.
So if I took the brine
from dill pickles
and used that as some of my
acid and made a dill pickle
vinaigrette and then pureed some
dill pickle to almost thicken
it up and add a little
contrasting flavor to it,
you could do that with
sweet and sour pickles, too.
So you just need to think that
you can make it with anything.
If you've got leftover
cooked butternut squash
and have a Vitamix
blender, I can
make you a butternut
squash vinaigrette
in about three seconds.
So you have all this
stuff in your kitchen
that you never use, like
a slow cooker, a pressure
cooker, a Vitamix
blender-- all this stuff
that you've accumulated
over a while.
Like, if you got married,
and filled out the registry,
and have all those
crazy, like, when
was the last time you
used that waffle maker?
So you just need to realize
that those tools are there
to make life easier,
but from scratch.
So just use that base.
And then you add
whatever you want to it.
It's whatever flavors
you want can go into it.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
Feel free to come up
and ask us questions.
And thanks for trying our pilot.